what's going on everybody and welcome to
an update to the web development in
Python with Django tutorial series it's
been about three years since I covered
Django so I think it's about time to do
a little bit of an update plus everybody
had been asking for something a little
more in-depth last time so hopefully
gonna kill two birds one stone so here
we have the Django homepage you actually
don't have to go here but this is their
website they've got documentation and
all that definitely check that out they
also have a pretty decent tutorial
that's worthy of following as well
especially if you guys are getting
confused on you know how things work in
Django and stuff like that so Django is
kind of a high initial investment for
you
or at least for most people because the
understanding had this whole
model-view-controller thing works and
all the connections that need to be made
can be kind of a challenge initially but
I promise if you stick through it's
definitely worth it in the end because
as your project grows and you need to
make changes or add new things using
something high-quality like Django is
gonna make it unbelievably easy for you
down the line it's just a little harder
to get started but hopefully I can make
it easier for you guys so let's go ahead
and get into it enough chitchat I think
the best way to learn Django and really
anything is to just do it I'm gonna
assume you guys know the basics of
Python if you don't follow any basics
tutorial you can go to Python program
that come to the fundamentals boom
there's a basic series there or anyone
else's just just know the basics of 5 ok
so let's go out and get started so the
first thing Oh couple other things I'm
going to mention is I'm gonna be using
the sublime text editor you don't have
to use sublime text you could use any
editor you want you could use notepad
plus plus or notepad for that matter or
pycharm or whatever use whatever you
want
the other thing is I'm gonna be doing
some of the development on a Windows
machine and then later we'll be on Linux
server since eventually if you're gonna
deploy a website chances are you're
gonna be on Linux somewhere so anyway
your operating system doesn't matter
I've also done a lot of development on
Mac I've done it on Windows and I've
done on Linux it just doesn't matter
so we're going to be using Python 3
point-seven here so also I'm assuming
you've got Python installed already and
with that let's go ahead and get started
so the first thing I'm gonna do I'm
gonna hopefully not drool out of my
mouth and open up a command window and
we're gonna go ahead and do a pip
install Jenko if you're on Linux or Mac
you might say instead like Python 3m pip
install Django or something like that if
you're on Windows it's PIP if you have
multiple versions of Python then it
would be like PI - three point seven MN
Stahl okay I'm assuming like I said
though you guys already know that so
take note we're using Django two point
one point five here you don't have to
use the exact version I use just know
that as things progress things might be
a little different from what I've seen a
lot of things are still backwards
compatible and it's like totally fine
things aren't getting deprecated but
sometimes things are so if something's
not working out for you for whatever
reason you could try to install the
exact same version as I'm using to see
if it's just a difference in version so
for example if you wanted to you could
also say pip install Django double
equals two point one point five and that
will install exactly version two point
one point five now we'll just say before
you deploy your your creation make sure
you're using the latest version of
Django there's lots of things that
change over time one of those things is
like security fixes and stuff so if
you're using an outdated Django you you
might be making a mistake so so the only
reason you should install a specific
version that I'm using here is just so
you could follow along and just learn
about Django and then later learn what
what's the difference between let's say
Django 2 and Django 2.5 or something
like that but probably unless this first
number changes like Django 3 something
you should probably will get away with
following along anyway let's see if
we're done with thee we are done with
the install when you install Django you
get a little command line thing called
Django admin we can do all these things
with Django admin but the main thing
that we're gonna do is start a project
and trying to think here that's probably
one of the main things that you're
actually going to use Django admin for
apparently you can do quite a few other
things with Django admin but instead
you'll be using a different script so
anyways what we're gonna say is Django
admin start project and we're gonna call
this project my site the way Django
works is it assumes all web sites are
actually just a collection of apps it
could just be one app for sure but it's
probably a collection of apps so
consider a website that has like a forum
store and like a blog or something like
that okay each of those things are
separate apps you have a forum app
you've got a Store app and a blog app
okay that's how Django sees things so
when we start a project our project is
called my site and within my site we're
gonna have a bunch of apps that do
things the thing that we're gonna do is
we're gonna create a website that's like
Python programming dotnet I've been
considering switching Python programming
at net over to Django currently it's
written in flask and for the reasons I
mentioned before as the whoops as a
project grows in flask trying to add new
elements and change things over time
becomes very tedious with Django it's
just not so I mean this always makes me
think of a comet comic I've done it
again Wow if I could type haven't I I
bet if I go to images hopefully we're
not seen yet hopefully nothing on here
is what we should save searches on
anyways this is the comic I always think
of you know you start off a project you
think you're doing great and then at the
end of the day it looks something more
like this and initially as we're setting
up Django it's gonna feel like we're
doing this but the thing is that's as
complex as it will ever get as opposed
to a project like Python programming at
net where there's so many little
connections going all over the place it
really is a challenge I I do think it's
worth it to use Django long term it's
just hard to initially get into it but
anyways start project my site boom let's
create my site and what's gonna happen
is we should have a new directory we
sure do called my site this is your your
project right inside of your project you
have another
directory called my site and then we
have managed PI which is actually what
we're going to use to do much of the
things coming up so inside of this my
site directory this is kind of like an
app already but I'm going to refer to
this there's probably a special term in
Django
I just don't know it I'm gonna call this
your like primary app inside of this app
really all this app is gonna do is point
to your other apps you're not gonna use
this you're gonna actually develop in
here other than to point to other apps
and adjust the settings other than that
you're not gonna really do anything I'm
just going to zoom in a little bit so
coming back out to this directory we
want to play with manage pie so I'm
going to open up a command window here
if you hold shift and right click by the
way that's how I get that you also if
you're on Windows can just do CMD and
that should also open up a command
window right where you are so the first
thing that we're going to do is start an
app so I'm gonna say let's say pie - 3.7
I actually can just say Python because I
don't have one version but anyways pie
3.7 manage pie start app and then we're
gonna call this app main so this will be
like the main core of the website so for
me this is where like we're gonna put
like tutorials like the main aspect is
tutorials and if anything I could
probably call this tutorials as well but
I'm probably gonna want to put other
things inside of main besides just
tutorials so I'm gonna call it main for
now so we've created an app called main
if we come back we should see we've got
another directory here called
main if we open that up it looks a lot
like our my site directory or our
primary app but we've got actually some
extra things here and as we can see
we've got models views where's the
controller we actually don't have any
controller here but we'll get there
I promise so what we want to do now is
let's go ahead I'm gonna get this just
to stay running now so what I'm gonna
say I'm gonna move have to command
prompts here the first one I'm gonna do
is we're gonna use manage PI and we're
actually just gonna say
run server run server and what this does
is runs your development server you in
theory could run a whole website off of
this it just isn't recommended probably
for all sorts of reasons including
security reasons anyway you can see
we've got some migration issues that we
can worry about later but mainly we can
see that the website is now running at
basically local host on port 8000 so
let's head there let's see what we got
paste okay so you get this little
beautiful imagery and it just kind of
notifies you hey you things are working
sort of up to this point but rather than
having this kind of display I think it's
a little cooler to have you know control
like how do I change all of these things
so let's get into it so first of all
with the Model View controller it kind
of works almost like in Reverse of that
you've got your controller which
basically takes the URL that whoever
typed in or clicked on a link that went
to that URL the controller takes that
URL and maps that to a view and then
that view returns the template now most
of the time that view is also going to
interface with your models but it
doesn't actually have to really you just
need a controller and a view to return
something so let's go ahead and do that
just so we can start to pick up how all
of this this stuff works so the first
thing that we're going to do is let's
just create inside of main here we don't
have a URL spy so we need to create one
the other thing we could do is go into
my site take this URL stop hi I'm just
going to say copy that and then I'm
gonna come into Maine paste and now we
have a URL spy I'd love to know like why
it doesn't by default
come like when you start a new app why
doesn't have a URL spy by default if
anybody actually knows that'd be cool
so this is like the first time I'm using
this this machine so
I've got to add sublime text really
quick to the thing that I want to open
great the other thing I probably need to
do before I forget indent using spaces
done okay so this is what our URLs by
just make sure you're in Maine not my
site actually I think it would make most
sense to start in in the my site you
were all stop hi because when someone
first comes here what its gonna do is
its first gonna look to your primary app
and it's gonna look at that URLs dot pi
and then it's going to see do we have a
URL pattern that matches and it needs to
have a URL pattern that matches but
generally your primary app is just going
to have a pattern that matches and
points to some other app so the first
thing we're gonna actually do let me go
file open folder and then let's open my
site and then I'm just gonna close this
and I think this is how we're gonna
interact from here out so I'm gonna go
into first let's go to my site URLs pi
so primary app I switched around don't
get confused it's your fault so what we
want to do here is we just need to take
this because it's our primary app and
point it to our new app called
main so we're gonna add another path
here I'm just going to copy this come
down here and I'm gonna paste and then
what I'm going to say is we're gonna
well first let's also import include and
then what we're gonna say for this path
is an empty path so homepage no other
URLs are being submitted here we want to
include main URLs so whenever someone
comes to just just the home page and
there's nothing else that this path is
gonna match so then it's gonna say okay
let's go to main dot URLs now so then
we're gonna go to main URLs make sure
you're in main URLs and now what we want
to do is actually we don't need add
in here so I'm gonna delete that for now
and then we are gonna say and we don't
need this admin either will keep path
and then the other thing we're gonna do
is from just relative import and then
we're gonna pass an app name and we're
gonna say app name equals main this is
useful later on when you're trying to
create custom URLs that will point to a
specific view but you don't actually
have to hard code the URL it's all
totally dynamic so right now we're not
using that but I just don't want to
forget about it later and you might as
well just always throw this in because
eventually you'll want to have that
functionality and you'll try to use it
because you saw it in an example
somewhere or something and it's not
gonna work and you're gonna be like wait
what so anyway we'll throw that in there
for now so then we're gonna say a path
and again the path would be homepage
because like right now all paths will
lead to this URL spy so but for now
we're gonna say okay the empty path is
gonna point towards a views dot home
page and then we're going to give this
also a name called home page I'm gonna
put a comma here before I forget because
later on we'll add more paths and throw
a syntax error if we mess that up okay
so going back over someone comes here
they visit the home page first we go to
our primary app comes here says oh hey
look here's a path that matches what
they just put in there's nothing else
here cool what do we do include main dot
URLs fine boom points to main dot URLs
we come here path ah okay this points to
a view and it's the home page function
in that view okay great unfortunately we
don't have the view done so if we come
into our main area here and in fact I'd
said I was going to keep using this so I
think we'll keep using this if we come
into main we can click on View spy and
here we have what we need to bring in
views now render is used to render
templates I just want to pass a simple
string right now I don't want to get
into templates so the next thing I'm
gonna say is from Django HTTP you
or HTTP response now define homepage and
then we're gonna pass a request so
basically all your actual views if you
have like a helper function or something
and obviously doesn't need requests but
for any actual view you pass requests
always and then obviously this is the
name that we passed right here right we
said views dot homepage so that's why
it's called homepage now all we're gonna
say is return HTTP response and then we
can pass actual HTML here even so we
could say wow this is an tutorial and
you can feel free to put whatever you
want in there I'm gonna say awesome okay
save that great so now let's make sure
our servers still running did we hit any
errors I don't see anything just yet so
let's come over here let us refresh the
page boom let me zoom in a little bit
just so everybody can see how what kind
of a tutorial oh it's awesome tutorial
okay I think this is a good stopping
point before we get into the next
tutorial which is where we're gonna talk
about models and stuff like that and
quickly start to ramp up but the big
thing is you have to understand
even's is this basic stuff cuz that was
actually a lot of work to go through
just to return some text on a page so
what I strongly suggest you do is after
this video before you go to the next one
is try to do everything we just did on
your own without needing to look
anything up I mean obviously you might
forget some of like the import names or
something like that but even then it's
just denko HTTP HTTP response and then
the only other import you need is the
include here so you should be able to do
this completely on your own now and so
what I would suggest you do is create a
new you know start a new project and try
to do all the things that we've done up
to this point without needing to
reference anything obviously as you as
time goes on that won't be necessary
that you can like make an entire website
without being it'll look anything up but
it's um
or not that you understand how these
initial connections are made before you
continue on because it only gets a
little more complex from here so anyways
that's it for now a quick shout out to
my most recent channel members Dinesh
Kumar Luciano Cena who knits and Nathon
II and you day manchanda thank you guys
very much for your support you guys are
awesome
also side note this series is sponsored
in part by Linode which is who i've
actually used to host Python programming
at net for like years also they're my
basically they're my main host for like
my larger websites and we'll be using
Linode as as our deployment Virtual
Private servers down the line but for
quite a while we'll just develop locally
because I think that's really the way to
go anyways but if you want to check out
Leonard or you need a hosting solution
I'll put a link in the description from
them but later on will actually go
through how you can actually launch a
django application on Linode and
actually you know why something like
Linode is better than some of the other
options that you have out there trust me
I've used all of them so anyways that's
it for now questions comments concerns
whatever feel free to leave them below
also we have a discord service just
discord GG slash centex in your browser
get you there come hang out come chat
with us ask questions whatever tell me
how how I can improve my tutorials all
that kind of stuff anyways I will see
you guys in the next video